if you're scared you're not going to
take the chances that you need to take
to to realize your dreams if you are
making a decision based out of fear you
lose step towards your fear is the step
into bravery rise and shine it's an
spresso time what's up belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message don't
let fear stop you over you will smith
also if you want to know what Will Smith
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet I look at
the world through a lens of comedy my
natural reaction is always no matter
when something happens and I can't even
help it it's why is that funny
I've never seen myself as particularly
talented where I excel is I'm willing to
die in the process of acquiring skill
[Music]
my parents drove us cross-country - we
were going to California for a family
reunion so we drove to the Grand Canyon
and we got there and I like I remember
having a deeply meaningful experience of
how beautiful it was but I was terrified
to walk up to the edge and all my
brothers and sisters and my whole family
walked up to the edge and I stayed back
scared to to take in beauty if you're
scared you're not going to take the
chances that you need to take - to
realize your dreams and that was the
thing for me I don't mind being scared
but I'm still gonna do it the reason why
you are stuck is because you are afraid
of taking action and you've convinced
yourself that there is a logical reason
for you to stay in mediocrity anytime
you want to go off and do something and
you hesitate and the next words out of
your mouth are I'm afraid of filling the
blank then you have to stop and
recognize that you have to go and do
that thing making decisions based out of
fear is your cancer it is the single
biggest thing that is crippling your
success and until you fix it you will
talk yourself down from your big ideas
for life I had a young entrepreneur come
on my morning show and asked me if he
should go and quit his university take a
year off to go work for his mentor in a
different City
so I asked him well what's on his mind
and the first thing he said was well I'm
afraid ding ding ding ding ding ding as
soon as you say that lights need to be
going off in your head if your answers
ever well I'm afraid his answer was well
I'm afraid that if I leave I may not be
able to get back in that it's gonna be
hard for me to come back and join the
program if that year doesn't work out
that is the wrong filter through which
to make a decision if you are making a
decision based out of fear you lose
because he'll end up not going to take
that job which you really want to take
not going to work for that mentor who he
really wants to work for because he's
afraid
and then when he graduates in two years
that opportunity like a little closed it
won't be there anymore and ultimately he
loses he took the safe sure bet instead
of the one that he actually wanted to
take and he hates his life for now you
need to understand that there is a
window on the opportunities of your
ideas there is a window of opportunity
that is not gonna stay open forever
that if you have something in your head
a dream a goal a vision something you
want to act on that will not be around
forever not just you won't be around
forever but that opportunity won't be
around forever this is a moment in time
that you have right now and if you don't
push all in you will regret it and if
the reason for you not push it all in is
because you're afraid of something you
are setting yourself up for failure and
unhappiness for life so how do you fix
it how do you prevent yourself from
screwing yourself over I have a
three-step process that I called the
bold identity and here's what it looks
like number one what's the big thing
that you want to do identify it I want
to do this thing if I did this thing I
would be super excited if you don't have
anything excited or something makes you
nervous in your schedule you hate your
life and so what is the big thing that
you dream of that you want to do step
number one number two super important
what would the boldest version of you do
you have a dream what would the boldest
most fearless version of you be doing
and write that down on your piece of
paper let go of any fears I go over any
inhibitions like go of all the reasons
why it's not gonna work
what would the boldest version of you do
and in step number three take immediate
action now this process of the bold
identity is not very complicated but
it's difficult to do it's hard to do
because it requires you to actually be
bold but here's the thing if you could
wear that hat just for a minute if you
wear that hat of boldness you take on
the bold identity and you say what would
the most bold version of myself do in
this situation that is actually the
right thing for you the decisions that
you make when you are feeling bold and
unstoppable are actually the things that
you should be doing those brief moments
of courage that you have and you decide
something that is actually the best
thing for you and then your brain will
start talking down from it your brain
will start thinking about all the
reasons
why you should not go off and do that
thing and so that's why the third step
of taking immediate action is so
important because just because you've
identified what the thing is that you
want to do and then you ask yourself
what would the boldest version of
yourself do when you get all pumped up
if you wait until tomorrow it's not
gonna happen you need to take immediate
action now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you but before that
question the day I want to know what
would the boldest version of you be
doing right now let me know put in the
comments below
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear how do you step into bravery
step that that's how you step into
bravery step take the step step
aggressively towards your fear and that
that step towards your fear is the step
into bravery because we're / scared of
what we don't know and there's only one
way to learn and to know and that is to
confront that fear you have to step you
have to go and this simple action
this simple attitude it answers so many
questions so many questions how do you
get to the gym every day you step you go
how do you how do you change your diet
you step you go how do you overcome fear
of failure or fear of success or fear of
fear itself you step and how do you face
the fear of the unknown your step don't
wait anymore don't think anymore don't
plan anymore don't contemplate anymore
don't make any more excuses or
justifications don't rationalize
anything else no no and no instead be
aggressive take action now and what is
the first action that you need to take
what's the first
step you need to take the first step you
need to take is just that step the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon if you want more
Will Smith check out the top 50 rules
video I made on him I think you'll enjoy
it the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you've got to take a shot you have
to live at the edge of your capabilities
you got to live where you're almost
certain you're gonna fail